pas
[Musique]
le samsah dv service d'accompagnement
médico-social pour adultes handicapés
déficients visuels de l'association
insan a organisé une journée portes
ouvertes ce samedi 17 juin dans leurs
locaux au moufia le samsah donc service
d'accompagnement médico-social donc
d'une structure un service dont qui
intervient à domicile pour accompagner
des personnes déficientes visuelles qui
ont besoin en fait d'accueillir et de
l'autonomie donc on intervient donc en
grande partie à domicile sur les lieux
de travail de la personne ou là où elle
vit donc notre travail consiste en fait
à proposer une coordination et des
rééducations un accompagnement social et
médico-social et c'était d'offrir la
possibilité au plus grand nombre de
venir découvrir les locaux du samsah
devenir de discuter que les
professionnels discuter avec les
bénéficiaires également et de vivre des
ateliers comme comme on a pu
le voir aujourd'hui s'écoute d'escalaïs
activités de la vie journalière parcours
psychomoteur ateliers d'accompagnement à
la parentalité auprès de parents
déficients visuels ou encore découverte
de jeux adaptés tête au programme de
cette journée
la première étape de travail en octobre
si ça va être surtout de leur faire
comprendre qu'ils ont encore des
capacités visuelles
parce que ce sont des personnes qui
arrivent qui sont et qui sont en train
de perdre la vue ou qui ont perdu la vie
dont qu'ils sont malades en la perte du
coup on a tout un travail de réassurance
et de leur dire s'il ya des capacités
jacques sont encore présentes et on va
les apprendre à les utiliser
donc aujourd'hui c'est un atelier de
découverte de la méditation par les
outils de la pédagogie perceptive donc
la pédagogie perceptive en fait c'est à
prendre est de plus en plus en lien avec
soin pour avoir un mieux-être physique
et psychologique
hier sam accueille actuellement près de
1200 enfants adolescents et adultes en
situation de handicap au sein de 24
établissements
[Musique]